did you know that paper Industries can
use radioactivity to ensure consistent
thickness throughout the paper that's
right but doesn't it make you wonder how
do you use radioactivity to do that well
let's find out if you have a very heavy
nucleus then there will be too many
protons in it causing repulsion making
the nucleus very unstable when that
happens it just spits out a helium
nucleus and becomes lighter now the
daugh nucleus is more stable this is
what we call an alpha DK and we've
talked a lot about this in great detail
in our previous video on Alpha DK but
guess what even light nuclei can be
unstable for a completely different
reason it has now nothing to do with the
to number of protons but now it has
something to do with the ratio of
protons and neutrons turns out that
certain ratios of protons and neutrons
just doesn't work for the nucleus making
it very unstable now what does it do now
how does it stabilize it well now it
under goes a beta dek in fact we will
see that there are two kinds of beta
dekay but what exactly happens over here
what is a beta particle well let's let's
explore all of that by taking a couple
of examples for our first example let's
consider carbon 14 it's a radioactive
isotope and it's unstable and so what it
does is it changes into nitrogen 14
spitting out a beta particle so again
the question is what's going on over
here what's this beta particle of course
we can Google it but where's the fun in
that instead let's put thinking caps on
and see if we can logically deduce this
the way I like to think about it is just
keep track of protons and neutrons I
mean if you look at Carbon it has six
protons in it and since the total number
of particles is 14 the remaining eight
must be neutrons so there are eight
neutrons in it okay what about nitrogen
well it has seven protons in it and
because mass number stayed the same oh
it's still the 14 um there must be seven
more neutrons in it now if you look at
the protons carefully you you can see
there's one extra proton over
here but if you look at the neutrons
well there is one extra Neutron over
here so can we guess what might have
happened well we can guess that the
neutron must have converted into a
proton and guess what that's exactly
what happened over here that's what a
beta DK is or at least one kind of beta
Decay is a neutron gets converted into a
proton that's incredible isn't it but
that's not it folks we can now also
guess what this particle is or at least
guess the part properties of this
particle just by using charge
conservation I mean whether you're
dealing with chemical processes or
nuclear processes the charges must
always be conserved now for all the
particles that we've accounted for of
course the charge stays conserved but
look at this a neutron is a neutral
particle but when it get converted to a
proton you get a positive charge now we
need to account for it the right hand
side should also be be neutral that
means along with the positive charge
there must be a negatively charged
particle that comes out that's what a be
a particle is it must have an equal
negative charge and guess what that is
it turns out you know experimentally we
found out that that is an electron so in
this particular process it's spitting
out an electron it's the good old
electron that we're all familiar with
except for the fact that it came from
the
nucleus and so whenever we have
electrons coming from the nucleus we
call it the beta minus particle and this
DK we call it the beta minus DK now of
course we need to write this in the same
notation because this is still the
nuclear process so how do we write that
well here we have a six but here we have
a seven so if I want this total number
to be six over here I just have to
subtract one so I'll write this as minus
one so that you have six here and 7 - 1
6 here and I know you must be wondering
well mahes what does it mean to have
minus one over here because this is
supposed to be the atomic number right
what does it mean to have a minus one of
an atomic number well don't worry too
much about it I like to think about it
it's just it's a negative charge that be
written over here I mean of course it
doesn't make sense for an electron you
know to have an atomic number or a mass
number but it's just a way to make sure
that you know our notation stay put okay
anyways so that's for this one what
about the mass number well the mass
number did not change so we have 14 here
14 here
that's good so we'll just write a zero
so that's how we represent an electron
in a nuclear process a beta minus
particle okay now you may be wondering
what is this question mark over here
we'll get to that but before that we'll
take another example this time we have
nitrogen turning into carbon why don't
you pause the video and do the same
analysis is even here is it the same
thing that's happening or something else
is happening is this the same beta
particle or something else why don't you
pause and give it a shot
all right let's see so again here there
are seven protons and since the total
mass number is 13 that means there are
six neutrons over here and over here
there are six
protons and again the mass number stayed
the same so there must be seven neutrons
over here again if you try to account
for them you will see there is one less
proton over here but there is one more
Neutron over here so what happened over
here hey it's the exact opposite this
time a proton got converted into
Neutron and again if we try to account
for the charge because charges must be
conserved there's a positive charge here
on the left hand side so on the right
hand side there must be positive this is
neutral that means this particle must be
positively charged it must have the same
charge as the proton so what is it Well
turns out this is what we call
a
positron but what exactly is a positron
think of positron as kind of a twin an
evil twin of electron it has almost all
the properties similar to that of an
electron like the same mass it will have
similar Spin and all the quantum
properties but just one thing will be
the opposite its charge will be opposite
okay so this is probably new particle
for us it's kind of like the electron
but with a positive charge we call this
positron however in general if you have
particles which have pretty much the
same properties as some other particles
except for a few that is the opposite
like maybe the charge or there are some
other Quantum properties that can be
opposite as well that case we call this
an antimatter so this positron is an
antimatter of electron proton also have
their antimatter it's called antiprotons
neutrons will also have their antimatter
it's called anti- neutrons and so so on
and so forth and the beautiful thing
about antimatter is that when antimatter
comes in contact with matter they
destroy each other they annihilate each
other giving out energy but anyways in
this bet DK we get a positron an anti-
electron antimatter of an electron that
comes out and because it is positively
charged we call this beta plus DK and
just like before just like before we
want to write it you know we want to
write it with the proper notations
this time we will write it+ one over
here and again don't worry too much
about what this is we're just making
sure that it you know this total number
stays the same and over here because the
mass number never changes we'll call it
zero so this is how you write a positron
in a nuclear process but that leaves us
with the last piece of the puzzle over
here what exactly are these question
marks we have accounted for all the
particles right well let me ask you this
we know that in any radioactive process
things are supposed to become more
stable more more stable means it should
have more less energy right well where
does the energy go well the energy goes
as the kinetic energy of these particles
but when we looked at it experimentally
we found that there was some missing
kinetic energy and to account for that
we hypothesize that there must be some
other particle that is taking away that
energy it must be neutral because we've
accounted for all the charges it must be
very tiny it must have very tiny mass
and it must not be interacting with a
lot of matter because we couldn't detect
it for a long time but eventually we did
you know what we call these particles we
call them neutrinos and anti neutrinos
even neutrinos have antimatter okay now
the big question is which one comes
where where do we get a neutrino and
where do we get an anti neutrino well it
turns out that wherever we get an
electron we get an anti- neutrino and
wherever we get an anti- electron that
is a positron that's where we get a
neutrino and so the symbol for neutrino
is new and the E over here just
represents that these neutros and antin
neutros came along with the electrons
and of course the bar over here
represents it's an anti-neutrino now we
might be overwhelmed thinking that oh my
god there are so many particles to keep
track of how will we remember this well
most of it can be done logically well
first of all if you zoom out you can see
a beta dek is basically neutrons
converting into proton or a proton
converting into a neutron and the reason
they do that is to improve the ratio
remember the whole reason was the proton
to Neutron ratio didn't work for them
making them unstable so by doing that
they will change that ratio that's the
whole motivation over here and then you
can use charge conservation to figure
out where we'll get a beta minus
particle and where we'll get a beta plus
particle and finally I remember that
wherever we have electron matter along
with that I'll get the antimatter of
neutrino anti neutrino and wherever I
have antimatter the positron which is
the anti-electron along with that I'll
get the normal matter neutrino which is
just the neutrino and by the way if you
are ever thinking about hey what allows
this to happen what kind of force allows
this weird Neutron to proton conversion
and proton to Neutron conversion well
it's the weak nuclear force the fourth
fundamental force of nature now let's
answer the original question how do
industries use beta dks to ensure
consistent thickness of papers Well
turns out that beta DK beta particles
sorry both positive and negative beta
particles they have a much higher
penetrating power compared to Alpha
particles remember alpha particles
because they are have a high ionization
power because they have plus two charge
and they're bulky they can easily stop
by even paper beta particles are much
tinier because they have a single charge
they have smaller ionization power and
because they're much more tiny they can
easily pass through paper in fact you
will need something like plastic or
glass or maybe aluminium to stop it so
now let's imagine what happens if you
have a lot of beta particles coming and
you keep paper in front of it well some
beta particles will get absorbed but a
lot of particles will get through now
the amount of particles that will get
through will depend upon the thickness
of the paper right because if you have a
if you have thicker paper more beta
particles get absorbed so by looking at
how many particles are coming out from
the back of the paper you can figure out
what the thickness at that particular
point is and this is how industri is use
you know beta DK to ensure that you have
a consistent thickness you can see we
can't use alpha particles for that
because it just gets stopped very easily
beta particles have the right
penetration power to do that job I find
this fascinating because I would have
never imagined using beta DK for
ensuring consistent thickness in paper I
mean that's just amazing if you ask me